hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels ich habe heute endlich mal
wieder ein mediterranes orientalisches
rezept und zwar geht es heute
kartoffelkäfer das sind so kleine
hackbällchen kartoffelkäfer schule sind
kleine hackfleischbällchen und diesen
geschichte mit kartoffeln in einer
auflaufform und es wird im ofen gebacken
das tolle an dem rezept ist man kann es
ganz gut vorbereiten also ist wirklich
so in zehn 15 minuten vorbereitet und
den rest erledigt sind einfach der
backofen
also ich könnte es zum beispiel auch
morgen zwar bereiten in den kühlschrank
stellen und dann einfach auspacken auf
türkisches bad escape vater des king und
ich zeige euch jetzt wie man es
herstellt und was sie alles dazu
benötigt für die hackbällchen brauche
ich 500 gramm hackfleisch habe ich ein
reines rinder hackfleisch eine zwiebel 1
knoblauchzehe zwei scheiben brot ich
habe hier acht kartoffeln die sind
mittellos und bereits geschält etwas
olivenöl
hier habe ich noch paprika süße und
schafe und an gewürzen brauche ich noch
pfeffer salz süßes paprikapulver etwas
kreuzkümmel und chili und später für die
soße noch ein bisschen tomatenmark ich
bereite zuerst mal die hackbällchen zu
und die habt da habe ich zwar schon in
einer großen schüssel dabei mischen ist
auch gleich drin und die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen muss sich jetzt ändern
zerkleinern
entweder können das jetzt mit einer
küchenrolle fein reiben oder einfach
kurz
hier gebe ich jetzt noch einen teelöffel
salz mit rein etwas pfeffer
etwas chili da gibt ihr einfach nach
belieben mit rein und einen halben
teelöffel kreuzkümmel das brot habe ich
jetzt noch etwas nass gemacht also im
wasser das muss man jetzt einmal kurz
ausdrücken
und damit es der kleine kinder zugegeben
jetzt muss ich alles gut durchmischen
ganz lecker ist es übrigens wenn ihr
dann noch etwas petersilie mit rein gibt
aber ich hatte leider gar keiner da und
dem rat wird noch mal einkaufen gehen
deswegen mord ohne so jetzt haben die
kleine hackbällchen und zwar sollen
dieser vom durchmesser etwa drei
zentimeter haben und wie lege ich jetzt
hier auf einem teller
als nächstes schneide ich jetzt die
kartoffeln in scheiben und da sollten
wir schreiben jetzt nicht zu dick sein
vor etwa 4 bis 5 mm er kommt kannst mir
helfen
so jetzt gehen wir die kartoffeln wieder
hier zurück und geben drei esslöffel
olivenöl mit rein ja schließlich
schwerstarbeit dann ein teelöffel salz
noch ein bisschen schärfer und einen
esslöffel paprikapulver
jetzt mischen wie sie und es geht am
einfachsten mit einem deckel deckel
drauf und dann einfach schütteln und
stets zeigen dass sich gekleckert habe
jetzt wird das ganze in eine auflaufform
geschichte dass er gleich im backofen
gebacken und ich habe jetzt hier eine
quadratische form die etwa 25 x 25 cm
und ist oder stein form das ist eine 100
m budget aber wir können zum beispiel
auch so ein rundes nehmen also meine
mama d azur glasgefäße das sitzt
natürlich auch richtig schön aus so und
jetzt werden die hackbällchen immer im
wechsel mit den kartoffelscheiben darein
geschichtet
die hug welchen kommen jetzt bei 200
grad in den vorgeheizten backofen für 25
minuten
in der zwischenzeit setzt sich schon mal
den türkischen reis auf dafür habt ihr
auch schon ein rezept bei mir in den
videos und ja dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder
er hat menschen war jetzt im backofen
und jetzt muss ich sie noch mit der soße
übergossen und ich habe jetzt hier noch
mit die schüssel in der freunde
kartoffeln drin waren
da gebe ich jetzt noch 50 milliliter
wasser rein und ein teelöffel
tomatenmark und verrührt es kurz und
gibt es nochmal drüber und dann müssen
die noch mal für fünf minuten in den
backofen in der mediterranen küche der
oftmals tomatenmark eines keine gerichte
mit rahmen sondern ehrte machen
tomaten magisches manila ich sage meiner
mutter genau das einfach drüber geben
und ich habe in der zwischenzeit auch
schon mal den reis gemacht da ist jetzt
auch gleich fertig und der morath kann
schon mal den tier stecken
ich bin noch richtig froh dass mal
wieder richtig was zu essen gibt also
was anderes als toppen törtchen und
überfluss
so jetzt richtig das essen an also wie
gesagt habe ich jetzt schon den reis
fertig und habe jetzt auch alles so etwa
fünf minuten abkühlen lassen und ich
recht dazu jetzt ein bisschen joghurt
also diese schützt so ein
zehnprozentiger joghurt leone diesmal
findet jedes mal dass wir mal still und
bescheiden sich die nach tschuldigung
hier steht teile jobs
menschen rat jetzt will ich so schön an
rechten für dich ist darüber gefallen
egal - essen für mich das was die
fotografische schlager je besser ich
finde es halt echten gerichtes camera
raw richtig gut vorbereiten kann man
einfach mal keine zeit hat großartig was
zu kochen hier poetisch schön vielleicht
ist ja nur zwei spielen lassen
die kartoffeln richtig bissfest nicht zu
locker sally sind sie froh sind wenn man
die hackbällchen etwas wenn man die
knusprig möchte können was er natürlich
vorher doch anbraten
aber zuletzt ein einfaches rezept sein
und eben ein schnelles ich finds echt
super der rat ist der kommentiert jetzt
nix irgendwie ich habe darauf gewartet
hast du was kommentiert aber er genießt
einfach genial
sally die bis zum nächsten runde ich
gratuliere dir danke ganz toll alles
klar ich schreib das rezept auf meinem
blog auf sallys - blog.de wenn ihr euch
gerne noch weitere türkische rezepte
wünscht dann schreibt mir das sind
eigentlich meine lieblingsrezepte muss
ich sagen weil die einfache müssen schon
wirklich sind einfach eine tolle
abwechslung zu meiner sonntags rezepten
die eigentlich immer nur aus sport und
kuchen bestehen ich finde die idee dazu
macht machen wobei ich finde freis auf
jeden fall reicht wird daraus leckere
suppe vorher eine türkische suppe dann
bis zum hauptgericht und back war es
macht es doppelt genau
also viel spaß und waren damit bestimmt
noch passiert viel spaß beim nachkochen
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder biss dann in der backzeit muss
sagen oh ja genau
also bei mir angesetzt 30 minuten im
backofen also 25 minuten ohne soße 500
mit soße aber natürlich kann es sein
dass je nach backofen ja auch bisschen
länger backen müssen als wir müssen
einfach gucken dass die kartoffeln durch
sind also wenn sie weich sind wir mit
der gabel reinsteckt und dann könnte das
herausnehmen darf jeder backofen anders
weil sie zwei backöfen auch verschiedene
wohl die gleiche marke und die
nebeneinander stehen wobei seinen keller
sind schon mal ganz anders als mein
teller zählt es unterschiedliche foto
und zwischen den takes spielt gewalt
darum gemacht entschuldigen
die hackbällchen kommen jetzt in den
backofen in zwei verschiedene sache die
hackbällchen community verspielten satz
und dann sag mal was anderes